the Supreme Court issued an unexpected
ruling yesterday in a case involving
black voters in Alabama the mostly
conservative Court ruled five to four
that the current republican-drawn
congressional districts in Alabama
likely violate the Voting Rights Act by
not fairly representing black voters the
state legislature will have to redraw
the districts before next year's
election joining us now to discuss the
surprising turn of events at CBS News
election law expert David Becker David
good to see you this morning so explain
to our viewers why was the state's
Congressional map so controversial in
the first place
well the republican-led legislature in
Alabama had drawn The Districts The
Seven districts in the Congressional map
in Alabama to include only one District
in which black voters could meaningfully
participate in other words to elect
candidates that they chose and that was
a little unusual here where black voters
proved in a state with 27 black voters
that they were entitled to more than one
likely two districts and the lower court
agreed with them and in a state like
Alabama where we see what we call
racially polarized voting in other words
whites vote in such a way as to defeat
black candidates of choice uh it was
determined that indeed black voters were
entitled to that additional district and
here the Supreme Court agreed with them
so David the state legislature will have
to redraw the maps going forward however
the 2022 midterm elections they're
already in the books so there's already
been an implication in this case in
addition to the redrawing in Alabama are
there other broader implications in that
state or nationally as a result of this
ruling yeah one of the things that was
really unexpected in this ruling is that
we had seen this court erode and weaken
and even eliminate some of the key
provisions of the Voting Rights Act over
the last decade and this decision put an
end to that this decision clearly
established the Voting Rights Act was
constitutional and that affects many
cases Nationwide there are cases going
on in Georgia and Louisiana right now
where it's likely additional black
districts will have to be drawn it could
affect some districts in Texas where
additional Hispanic districts could be
drawn but more importantly this isn't so
much about the politics this is really
about the minority voters who are
protected under the Voting Rights Act
and this is a case coming from the state
of course where uh bloody Sunday
occurred where John Lewis was beaten on
the Edmund Pettus bridge in 1965. yeah I
mean you touch on it briefly but it was
surprising considering the makeup of the
Court the five to four decision the
Court is primarily conservative does
this signal anything to you David
it's not clear exactly what it signals I
mean there are institutionalists on the
court conservative institutionalists
clearly uh chief justice Roberts falls
into that category Justice Kavanaugh
falls into that category and I think
after weakening the Voting Rights Act
over time they wanted to send a message
here they just applied the law that it
existed for decades to a very strong
fact pattern and I think that's a really
good thing in this case
all right David Becker for us thank you
David thank you